شكرا لك طاهر مشاهدينا اذا نواصل معكم
تغطيه التطورات في السودان حيث اكد الجيش
السوداني ان قائد القوات المسلحه عبد
الفتاح البرهان تسلم مبادره منظمه ايجاد
وهي منظمه شبه اقليميه مشاهدينا تضم ثماني
دول افريقيه وتاسست في عام سته وتسعين هذه
المنظمه اذا طرحت مبادره وافق عليها
مبدئيا البرهان واوضح الجيش ان المبادره
تتضمن تمديد الهدنه لمده 72 ساعه كما تنص
على افاد ممثلين عن الجيش وعن الدعم
السريع الى جبا عاصمه جنوب السودان
لمناقشه هذه المبادره وياتي ذلك بعدما
اعلن سفير الجزر القمر في فرنسا وعضو
مبادره الاتحاد الافريقي عبر العربيه ان
طرفي النزاع وافقا على مبادره افريقيه
للتسويه
[موسيقى]
المكالمتين مع
الجهتين استطاع ايضا ان يعرض عليهما
خريطه عمل هي في الحقيقه تهدف الى
دعوه الجهات المعنيه بالوضع السوداني الى
طاوله الحوار
وكذلك
دعوه المجتمع الدولي الى ان يقفوا على
جانب الاتحاد الافريقي من اجل ايجاد حل
تلقي
قبل ذلك اكد الجيش السوداني انه لا يوجد
تفاوض مع قوات الدعم السريع سواء في جنوب
السودان او اي دوله اخرى في الوقت الحالي
واكد الجيش السوداني ان المعركه الان هي
لحسم ما وصفه بتفلت قوات الدعم السريع
ودحرها من الخرطوم وفي تصريحات للعربيه
اوضح الجيش السوداني ان رئيس مجلس السياده
عبد الفتاح البرهان لا يسافر لدوله اخرى
للقاء ما وصفه بقائد التمرد في اشاره
لقائد القوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
هذا وقلا مصدر صحفي للعربيه ان العشرات
قتلوا في اشتباكات في ولايه دارفور وافاد
المصدر ان اشتباكات في مدينه الجنينه بين
الجيش والدعم السريع تحولت الى قتال قبلي
ادى الى مقتل العشرات واوضح ان الاشتباكات
وقعت بين قبيله المثاليت والقبائل العربيه
في الجنينه غرب دارفور من جهتها اعلنت
القبائل العربيه في بيان وقفه اطلاق النار
فورا داعيه منسوبيها كافه لضبط النفس
والالتزام الفوري بذلك
وبالاضافه لدارفور ما تزال الاشتباكاته
دائره في عدد من المناطق السودانيه
وبالاخص في العاصمه الخرطوم نتعرف على
تفاصيل اكثر مع الزميل الليالي
منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل انفجرت الاوضاع
داخل السودان بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
مناطق جغرافيه متباعده في هذا البلد
الشاسع شمالا مشاهدينا في المراوي في
الوسط في الخرطوم وفي الغرب في دارفور
الان في الاسبوع الثاني من هذه الاشتباكات
يبدو بان نقاط ونطاق هذه المواجهه الحاميه
بين الطرفين اصبحت اكثر تركيزا داخل
العاصمه الخرطوم اذا هذه العاصمه التي
يقال عنها مثلثه لماذا لانها تتكون من
ثلاث تجمعات سكانيه كما نتابع هنا
الخرطوم بحري ام درمان والخرطوم مدينه
الخرطوم جنوبا يمكن لنا ان نقول ان معظم
الاشتباكات الدائره الان في مدينه الخرطوم
الجنوبيه تنحصر حول نقطتين اساسيتين كما
نشاهد هنا قياده الولاده العامه للجيش
السوداني والمطار حول المطار هنا يقول
الجيش السوداني بان قوات الدعم السريع
تسيطر على المطر اما قياده الجيش القياده
العامه فيسعى الطرفان الان للسيطره عليها
لماذا لان هذه النقطه تعتبر استراتيجيه
بمسار هذا النزاع الدائر بين الطرفين اذا
تنحصر المواجهه حول المطار وحول القياده
العامه حيث توجد اشتباكات حاميه بين قوات
الجيش والدعم السريع في الخارج اما النقطه
الثالثه
للاشتباكات فهي طبعا شرق المطار تقع
اشتباكات في حي الرياض كما نشاهد هنا كما
تقع اشتباكات ايضا في منطقه القصر
الجمهوري غربي المطار واشتباكات اخرى في
حي الصحافه وفي حي جبره وفي الكلا جنوب
غرب المطار اذا هذه خارطه الاشتباكات بهذه
النقطه اما مشاهدينا في ام درمان في ام
درمان غربي النيل توجد اشتباكات متفرقه
بين الطرفين اذا
تحديدا الاشتباكات تنحصر هنا حول مقر
الاذاعه والتلفزيون كما نشاهد هنا بهذه
الاشتباكات الدائره بين الطرفين هنا قوات
الدعم السريع تقول بانها تسيطر على هذه
النقطه وتسيطر على مبنى الاذاعه
والتلفزيون بينما يسيطر الجيش على محتوى
البث عبر محطه خارجيه اما النقطه الخامسه
فهي في الخرطوم بحري الوضع هنا هادئ قليلا
واهدئ طبعا من الخرطوم لكنه يبقى محتدما
وقبل يومين كما تبعنا خرج سجناء من هذه
النقطه تحديدا
هي سجن كوبر والذي يعتبر من اشهر السجون
واكبر السجون في الخرطوم بحري بعدما قالت
الشرطه انها اضطرت لفعل ذلك بسبب انقطاع
خدمات المياه والكهرباء التي طبعا انقطعت
منذ بدا هذه الاشتباكات بين قوات الدعم
السريع وبين الجيش السوداني اذا مشاهدينا
كانت هذه ابرز نقاط المواجهه بين الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني التي كما قلنا
انها تنحصر الان في داخل العاصمه بمحيط
القياده العامه القصر الجمهوري ونقاط اخرى
كما فصلها
اذا الخبر الابرز في هذه الساعه ربما
سنشهد تفاوضا بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع في جوى عاصمه جنوب السودان
وهذا وفق مبادره طرحتها المنظمه الاقليميه
منظمه الايجاده التي تضم ثماني دول هي
اختصار للهيئه الحكوميه للتنميه الايجاد
البرهان تسلم مبادره الايجاد ويبدو انه
وافق عليها مبدئيا نتابع من الرياض معنا
صحفيه السودانيه في جريده الشرق الاوسط
فتح الرحمن يوسف استاذ فتح الرحمن اهلا
بكم هل علمت بدايه اي تفاصيل اضافيه حول
ما تتضمنه مبادره الايجاد
شكرا جزيلا شكرا على هذه الفرصه الطيبه
وتحيه لك وللمشاهدين الاعزاء حقيقه
المبادره هي توها ولدت في الساعات الاخيره
بعد ان ذكرها السيد وزير خارجيه جنوب
السودان السيد تانك وهو نفسه لم يعطي
تفاصيل عن هذه المبادره التي الان تتبلور
لتحتويها
او مظله الاتحاد الافريقي
اعتقد ان التفاصيل ستكون يعني تحتاج الى
مزيد من الوقت حتى يكون هناك تفاصيل
لانها ابرز حول هذه المبادره انه سيكون
الطرفان سيذهبان للتفاوض في جوبا كيف تنظر
الى الى موافقه البرهان مبدئيا على هذه
المبادره بتضمنها جلوس الطرفين
للتفاوض في جباء الجيش والدعم السريع
اعتقد من السابق لاوانه الحديث عن قبول
الدعوه لان البرهان الان اعتقد يعيش نشوه
الانتصار الجيش على الدعم السريع في مواقع
كثيره داخل
الخرطوم وخارج الخرطوم وبالتالي اعتقد ان
الجيش الان
يحاول ان يكسب الوقت لحسم المعركه كما
يقول في بياناته المتعدده والمخترفه اعتقد
اجابه البرهان او قبولا للدعوه ستكون فقط
لمجرد
تطيب الخواطر
لاشقاء والاصدقاء فقط
الى حين يعني يخلص او ينهي هذه المعركه
يجامل فقط الدول الافريقيه الثماني في
منظمه الايجاد تعتقد انه لن يوفد ممثلين
عن الجيش الى جبل التفاوض مع الدعم السريع
سيكون ذلك يعني في وقت لاحقه بعد ان يعلن
رسميا انه انتهى من المعركه والان يجب ان
يجلس الطرفين النزاع او طرفان النزاع يجلس
الى مائده الان هناك ايضا لا بد من حوار
لاحق ولست لا ارى له الان وجود في ظل
الحماس الذي يقضيه الجيش لانه يعني
معركته نحو مزيد من النجاح وتحقيق العديد
من المكاسب في ظل الغياب الدولي والاقليمي
وحتى الداخلي يعني حتى على مستوى قوه
سياسيه التي لم تكن بمستوى الحدث حتى الان
نعم لكن من تفاصيل ايضا القليله التي بدت
في هذه المبادره مبادره الايجاد انه سيكون
هناك تمديد للهدنه لاثنتين وسبعين ساعه
كذلك الا يمكن ان ينظر الى هذا على انه
مؤشر ايجابي ايضا
هو مؤشر اجابه ولكن لا يدل على ان هناك
يعني قبول واتفاق على
اطلاق حوار من هذا النوع في هذا التوقيت
بالتحديد
واعتقد كما قيل ان جيش كما قالت جيشا
البرهان لا اعتقد انه سوف يغادر الى خارج
البلاد في هذه الظروف ليدير حوار او من
ينوب عنه في من الجيش ليدير حوار خارج
الخرطوم اعتقد المساله الان هي الجيش يعكف
على يعني اداره معركته بحسم
يعني الوصول الى نهايات هذه المعركه
واعتقد يعني لاحقا بعد ان يحقق هذه
المكاسب التي يرجوها يمكن ان
يقبل الدعوه لان تكون هي
لحل لتصور لحل الازمه مستقبلا وليست الان
نعم طيب ولكن
الهدنه كيف هناك من يرى صحيح رغم الخروقات
والاشتباكات في بعض المناطق الا انه يمكن
التاسيس عليها كما يعتقد البعض بالنظر الى
يعني احترامها في بعض المناطق ام لا تعتقد
ان هذه الهدن يعني هي مجرد يعني اتفاق
شكلي
اعتقدت الفتنه هي اصلا يعني هي استجابه
لمحاوله معالجه الوضع الصحي الان والبطء
الانساني يعني هناك قتله وجرحى كسر وهناك
مستشفيات خارجه عن الخدمه وفي ازمه في
الادويه عزيمه في الكوادر الطبيه
وبالمقابل هناك زياده في عدد القتلى
والجرحى وهذا الوضع الانساني والوضع الصحي
يتطلب شيء من الهدنه يعني الهدنه هنا شيء
انساني بحته وليس له علاقه باداره المعركه
المعركه هي فقط تكون هي في اتجاهها الى
النهايات التي يعني انشودها الطرفان ولكن
تظل الهدنه يعني شيء مطلوب ايضا وهي ليست
الهدنه الاولى وليس الثانيه ولن تكون
الاخيره
نعم طيب بالحديث عن وضع الانساني ما
المعطيات التي لديك ان كان فيما يتعلق
بخدمات المياه والكهرباء وكذلك مساله
الجثث الملقاه في الشوارع التي بقيت ملقاه
في الشوارع
للاسف الشديد هناك يعني تظلل احصائيه يعني
المعلنه غير الاحصائيه الحقيقيه يعني وانا
تحدثت قبل قليل مع المدير الاقليمي لمنظمه
الصحه العالميه يتحدث عن ان العدد تجاوز
من حيث القتلى تجاوز ال500 وعدد الجرحى
والمصابين تجاوز الخمسه الاف وهذا في
ازدياد هذه يعني احصائيه معلنه ولكن
الاحصائيه الحقيقيه تظل بعيده كل البعد عن
هذه
الاحصائيه المعلنه لانه هناك قتله وشراء
وجرحى بعيدين عن العين وعن
المراقبه او عن الاسعافات وعن الفصل
للظروف التي يعلمها استاذ فتح الرحمن ارجو
ان تتفضل بالبقاء معنا نذهب الان الى ام
درمان على الضفه الاخرى من النيل المقابله
للخرطوم معنى من هناك مقداد حسن الصحفيه
السودانيه مقداد اهلا بك معنا هل الهدنه
صامده
اهلا وسهلا بك وبجميع مشاهدين
نعم الهدله لا تظل
تخترق بالاشتباكات المتعدده في مناطق
مختلفه من اندرمان وما زال الطرفان
بعضهما البعض وما زلت الاشتباكات واماكن
السيطره بين اتهامات المضاده هنالك قصف
وتحديق الطائرات اليوم في مناطق الصالحه
ومناطق
الفتيحاب وكذلك ابو سعيد التي يقول الجيش
السوداني انه استهدف هذه المناطق لانها
تحتوي على اماكن التفكر قوات الدعم السريع
وكذلك هنالك تحليق للطائرات في هذه
المنطقه هذه الصباح كذلك هنالك اشتباكات
واخور قبائل في منطقه صالحه بحسب شهود
عيان كانت هنالك ثلاث قذائف وق عت في
المنطقه
من التثبت من الجهه التي اطلقت هذه
القذائف مقداد
لا وجود
تثبت هنالك طريق
الاشتباكات تحدثها المواطنين ياتون الى
هذه المناطق التي قد تخلف جرح او تخلف بعد
ان تتم الاشتراكات وبالتالي هنالك بيانات
من الجيش هنالك
بخيله لتثبت من اطلق او من لكن تتجدد
الاشتباكات حتى هذا اليوم في منطقه يشرد
البشير بحسب حسب شهور
المنطقه اما بالنسبه للوضع الانساني
والوضع
الصحي في منطقه ام درمان
تشهد ثيابا قليلا مقارنه في البحري
والخصوم هنالك حركه للمؤترات في المناطق
الشماليه والمناطق الغربيه بحكم ان هذه
المناطق مقداد
يعني مع هذه الاحداث في السودان بتنك
صحفيين يعني نطلع على المزيد من التفاصيل
خاصه عن الجغرافيا السودانيه يعني اكثر
قربا يعني من
وضع العاصمه السودانيه او الجغرافيه
العاصمه السودانيه اكثر بانها تتكون من
ثلاث مناطق الخرطوم مدينه الخرطوم الخرطوم
بحري وام درمان هل الوضع الانساني مختلف
في في هذه المناطق الثلاث يعني هو افضل من
غيره في منطقه اخرى ام لا هو الوضع تماما
مشابه
متشابه اقصد
للاختلاف الجغرافيا باختلاف المواقع
السياديه في كل من المدرسه ثلاث هناك
اختلاف تماما في الوضع الصحي والوضع
الانساني لمسك المجرى ثلاث محاربه
للجيش السوداني والدعم السريع وبالتالي
العكس ذلك سلبا على الاوضاع الانسانيه
لانها لان لان جميع المواقع السياديه
وجميع المراكز الانتاج هما الاكبر
بتلكي مدينتين وبالتالي الوضع الانسان
والصحي في مدينه ام درمان مع انها اكبر
جغرافيا لانها تمتد شمالا وجنوبا موازيه
للمدينتين الخرطوم والخطوبه لشمالا لكن
المواقع
الافتراسيه تظل في مدينه الخرطوم بوجه على
وجه الدقه حيث هو القصر الرئاسي والمطار
الخرطوم الدولي
خدمات المياه والكهرباء كيف هي في ام
درمان
خدمات المياه والكهرباء واجهت بعض المشاكل
في الايام الاولى لكن تظل حتى هذه اللحظه
في مناطق كثيره جدا مع مع وجود بعض
المناطق التي المياه وليعاني المواطنين
لكن مقارنه من الخطوبه هي اقل
سؤال الاخير مقداد لو سمحت لي امنيا هناك
خشيه طبعا مع خروج المساجين من السجون
طبعا مع الانفلات الامني هناك خشيه من
اعمال نهب وسرقه الى اي حد يعني هذا
الشعور يعني يسيطر على السكان في ام درمان
علي
بعد اكثر من
7000 سجين الهدى
وبالتالي مما زاد مخاوف السودانيين في كل
من المدن الثلاث
اصبح المواطنون يعملون لساعات المناطق
التي تعمل اصبح يعملون من النهار والاغلب
المناطق او المناطق الحيويه اغلق ابوابها
مبكرا كذلك هنالك مشاهد
يعتبر يعتبرها الكثير
بعصامات وكذلك
ياخذون الحيطه والحذر فبالتالي هنالك يعني
هدوء نسبي حذر يمكن لما يمكن ان يحدث لك
في اي لحظه المواطنون اصبحوا اكثر خشيه
واكثر
حيطه وحذرا مما قد
بعض هذه شكرا جزيلا لك مقداد حسن الصحفي
السوداني كنت معنا من اندرمان
اذا هناك مبادره لتمديد الهدنه 72 ساعه
لكن الهدى تفشل باستمرار بينما هناك خطر
اخر هو دخول مجموعات عسكريه خاصه على الخط
لتعقد المعادله وتزيد مخاوف الجهات
الدوليه
مع دعوات وقف اطلاق النار في السودان
والهدنات التي لا تدوم الا قليلا تصاعدت
مخاوف حول دخول مجموعه فاغنر العسكريه
الروسيه على خط الصراع دعم باسلحه من قوات
فاجنر ما هي دقه هذه المعلومات اولا
بالنسبه لكم سياده الفريق
نحن نتحرى من دقه هذه المعلومات كان هذا
رد البرهان على سؤال حول وجود فاغنر في
السودان في لقاء مع قناه العربيه في
الثاني والعشرين من هذا الشهر اما دجلو
فعند سؤاله عن علاقه الدعم السريع
بالمجموعه العسكريه الخاصه فقد انكر
اول المعبرين عن قلقهم من وجود محتمل
لمرتزقه فاجنر كان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيين
مقابل القلق الامريكي موقف رسمي روسي
يتجاهل المخاوف الامريكيه
وزير الخارجيه الروسي
اعتبر تعامل الدول الافريقيه مع فاغنر
كشركه خاصه شانا داخليا وان لها الحق في
ذلك ولكن لم يتبين حتى الان ما اذا كان
لمرتزقه
وجود على الميدان في السودان انس النماسي
العربيه
اذا ونعود الى ضيفنا في
الرياض الصحفي السودانيه في جريده الشرق
الاوسط فتح الرحمن يوسف
فتح الرحمن هناك من يصف المشهد في السودان
اليوم بانه دخل في فوضى عارمه يعني
وشهادات الاجانب الذين تم اجلائهم من
السودان يتحدثون بالاساس عن انعدام الامن
وتكرار السرقات طبعا وهناك بعض الاشخاص
الذين يتجولون بالاسلحه البيضاء هل هذا
الوضع بات عاما هذه الفوضى يعني باتت
ملاحظه بشكل كبير في السودان ام هذه في
بعض المناطق فقط
طبعا
بالتاكيد الحرب في العاده تلد الخراب
والتمارب وبالتاكيد
يعني
تثمر عنا وضع امني مضطرب ومخل وهذا ما حدث
ونشاهده الان في الخرطوم ولكن بطبيعه
الحال هذه الفوضى التي تعاني منها الخرطوم
في مدنها ثلاث لن تجدها في مواقع اخرى
يعني لن تجدها في ولايه الجزيره في مدني
لن تجدها في ولايه الشماليه في دنقله لن
تجدها في الشرق في بورسودان لن تجدها في
ولايات اخرى عدا الولايات الغربيه اللي هي
ولايه
في بعض ولايات دارفور نجد هناك عراق
واشتباك يعني يزعزع الامن وهناك بالتاكيد
هناك بعض العناصر المتفلته التي تعيش في
مثل هذه الاجواء المسممه لتنهب وتمارس
النهب المنظمه الغير منظم والعشوائي وحرق
الاسواق والى اخره هذا شيء يعني يعني اصلا
في دارفور من وقت النتائج هذا الاقتتال
طيب اليوم برز ايضا استاذ فتح الرحمن لو
سمحت لي عذرا على المقاطعه كذلك تجدد
الاشتباك في
دارفور في غرب دارفور في الاشتباكات
القبليه الى اي حد برايك هذا انفجار اخر
مرتقب
سيزيد الطين بله في السودان
بالتاكيد يعني كان هذا متوقع لانه في
الاساس المنشا المنشا قوات الدعم السريع
والموقع الجغرافي الذي ولدت فيه والذي
خلصت بخدمته
وغرب سودان الولايات دارفور وبالتالي وفي
الاساس والكل يعلم ان قوات الدعم السريع
هي نشات
نشاه يعني خاصه
وتتميز بانها الى حد ما تجمع عناصر
تنتمي الى قبائل محدده ومعروفه ومن هنا
يكون يعني قوات الدعم السريع مركزها
الاساسي في ولايات غرب السودان اللي هي في
دارفور ومن ثم سيكون هناك يعني بالتاكيد
يعني مساله دعم وتحفيز في قوات الدعم
السريع التي تقاتل في الخرطوم لتحفزها
لابد ان تشتغل على مساله خلق بلبله وتزايد
المخاطر وتشتيت افكار الجيش السوداني حتى
يعني تحاول ان تناصر قواتها او ممثليها في
ولايات الخرطوم الثلاثاء ولايه الخرطوم في
عواصمها الثلاثه نعم طيب اريد ان اسالك عن
تطور كان بارزا ايضا بالامس خروج
القياديين من المؤتمر الوطني او من النظام
السابق استاذ فتح الرحمن هل من مستجدات
جديده اليوم في ظل طبعا المخاوف من هذا
التطور في الازمه السودانيه
والله انا صراحه يعني واكون واضح جدا في
هذا المنحه يعني ليس من الخطوره بمكان
يعني
يخرج سياسيون المعتقل المعروف والشهير
كوبر الى فيصل هذا الانفلات الامني الذي
يعني انتظم سائر
الخرطوم
والاسود هذا كله هو السجون الاخرى التي
يعني يهمها عدد كبير من السجناء
يعني
الذين مارسوا القتلى والنصبه
والسرقه والنهب وهم يعني يعني على مستويات
مختلفه ولكنهم في شريحه كبيره منهم يعني
مجرمين ومجرمين يعني على على درجه كبيره
جدا يعني لما يخرجوا في هذا الوضع المنفرد
امنيا في في الخرطوم سيزيد
سوءا يعني يزيد الطين بالله زي ما يقولون
وهو في نفس الوقت يعني يعني هو جزء وخطيئه
يعني تحسب على نظام قوات الدعم السريع لان
هي هي من بادرت بهذه المساله خليني لو
سمحت لي بس اجي لك على مساله السياسيين
المؤتمر الوطني اعتقد
الناس من المفترض ان يستفيدوا من الدرس
يعني مساله الاخصاء هذه ومساله الابتعاد
عن المؤتمر الوطني ومساله شيطنه المؤتمر
الوطني هذه مساله يعني لن تفيد البلاد ولن
تخلق استقرار انا اعتقد من الحكمه بمكان
ان يحاول يحاول الطيف السياسي الان ان
يستفيد من السياسيين التابعين المؤتمر
الوطني يعني ان
يحاولوا يشتغلوا في اتجاه الايجابي
لمحاوله احتواء هذا الوضع لانه هم جزء
اصيل نحن لو عن وجودهم الان في الساحه باي
شكل من الاشكال موجودون وبالتالي يعني حتى
لا نغطي رؤوسنا في الرمال ونتحدث عن
شياطين وعن الناس هم يعملون يعني صحيح
هناك اخطاء
ولكن هناك يقول قائل الان انه ولكن يعني
هم مدانون عمليا وهم مسجون في السجن يعني
مدنون من القضاء السوداني وتم يعني ازاحه
هذا النظام بثوره شعبيه باراده شعبيه
باراده السودانيين قبل اربع سنوات
لا لا ليس هناك مشكله بتاتا يعني من من
الاهميه بمكان ان يحاسب كل مؤتمر وطني كل
من كان منتبه للمعتبر الوطني وسبته عليه
يعني خطيئه معينه
قتل محدد اي شيء هذا قانون على الجميع لا
باس منه بالعكس هذا يبسط العداله ولكن انا
اتحدث عن ان لا يؤخذ المؤتمر ككل كتله لان
مؤتمر الوطني في حد ذاته هو ليس اخوان
المسلمين وليس اسلاميين الاسلاميين
والاقوال المسلمين في المؤتمر الوطني 13%
فقط يعني هم صحيح نافذين ولكن 13% وهناك
كثير من القوه السياسيه في مختلف الاحزاب
التي تسيدت المشهد السياسي قالت جزء ان
اصيله من هذا المؤتمر وفي النهايه يعني
يعني عملت تسويات سياسيه واتفاقيات هنا
وهناك ودخلت بمسميات
بمناصب مختلفه في في المؤتمر الوطني
حزبا واحدا لم يشارك في هذه في هذا
المؤتمر بفساده وبكله بكلياته يعني نعم
لانه يعني
[موسيقى]
طبيعي ان يكون هناك تعاون يعني صحيح يعني
في النهايه شكرا
للاسف انتهى وقتي في هذا الجزء لو سمحت
تفضل تفضل اختم بحجم بسيطه اختم بانه انا
اختم بان هناك
للاستفاده من هذا الجو لاحتواء كل
المكونات السياسيه
لتعزيز وتنشيط
ودفع الحوار الى نهايات افضل وسعيده للشعب
استطالت مده معاناه وشقاوه في بلد يعني
يرقد على بحيره من المياه ويرقد على على
مناجم من الذهب والفضه واليورانيوم وعليه
انهار وبحار يعني تغني وتصبر وتغذي العالم
والا سنكون نحن نتقاتل على ارض يتاكلها
الاعداء والمكائبين من حولنا نعم ولكن
يعني للموضوعيه يعني حميدتي كان نفى هذه
الاتهامات في تصريحات للعربيه
ان يكون السيطره على هذه الاموال او
استفاد من هذه الاموال
لا هناك
هناك تقدر ثروته حتى الان 22 بلياردو
دولار ويصرف على جنوده ما يعادل 28 مليون
دولار هذه ميزانيه دوله يا رجل يعني هناك
حقيقه يعني لابد من معالجه الوضع يعني
ليست هناك السودان قلق للشعب كله يا رجل
فلابد ان يكون هناك تسويه يعني فعلا عادله
وتبسط العدل وتنشر العدل ويكون هناك فعلا
حتى يعني نحن نتكلم على المساواه السياسيه
والمساواه الماديه والحقوق الانسان وكله
وهذا كله لا جزء لا يتجزا من بعضه يعني
شكرا جزيلا لك طبعا نحترم وجهه نظرك طبعا
والطرف الاخر طبعا الحريه في التعبير عن
وجهه نظره كذلك والدفاع عن رايه شكرا
جزيلا لك من الرياضه صحفيه السودانيه في
جريده الشرق الاوسط فتح الرحمن يوسف
اظهرت صور متداوله على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تحركا لقوات كبيره من الجيش الى
الخرطوم وافادت مصادر بان تلك القوات
تحركت من ولايات الجزيره النيل الابيض
ونهر النيل
[موسيقى]
وقف
مواطنين سالمين دايرين ياكلوا لقمه الايش
المشكله بقى خطير علينا
كل حاجه يعني الناس دي الحاجات دي للناس
المساكين وقرايه للصناعيه للنزل مستغرب
اليوم باليوم
[تصفيق]
في الكرسي انا الدائري منكم بس تهزوا
مع استمرار المواجهات في السودان والجهود
الدوليه المبذوله لوقف اطلاق النار اعلن
البيت الابيض عن العمل مع طرفي الصراع في
السودان لتمديد وقف اطلاق النار لوقف
العنف وتامين المسارات الانسانيه مشيرا
الى ان وقف اطلاق النار في السودان مستمر
رغم بعض الخروقات بالاضافه الى عمليات
القصف العشوائي التي اسفرت عن مقتل مدنيين
بينهم امريكي هو الثاني حتى الان البيت
الابيض اكد على مواصله العمل لتامين خروج
مواطن امريكي يريد مغادره الاراضي
السودانيه
كثيرا ما اصطدم السودانيون بمصطلح الجهه
الثالثه عند محاوله البحث عن المتسبب في
بعض من الاحداث التي مرت على البلاد حينها
كانت مختلفه الاطراف ترمي التهمه على هذا
الطرف المجهول واليوم يعود هذا المصطلح
للواجهه فمن هي هذه الجهه الثالثه
المواجهات تتكرر في السودان والمتهم واحد
قبل اسقاط الرئيس السابق عمر البشير قتل
متظاهرون مناوون له عام 2019 والقيت
التهمه على جهه ثالثه بحسب مدير المخابرات
انذاك صلاح عبد الله غوش
انتهى حكم البشير وبعد اشهر من التنازع
السياسي بين المكونين المدني والعسكري حدث
فضه اعتصام القياده ايضا تكرر قتل
المتظاهرين وشماعه التي تلقى عليها التهم
لم تتغير
في وقتنا الحاضر هذه الجهه الثالثه ايضا
هي المتهمه باداره النزاع اول وقوف وراء
النزاع العسكري الدائر وهي قوه او فلول
نظام البشير السابق طرفان نزاع تبادل
الاتهامات وفي مقابله مع العربيه قال قائد
قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو ان من
يدير الحرب على قواته هم قيادات في حزب
المؤتمر الوطني المنحل حزب الرئيس السابق
عمر البشير واعتبر انهم من يقودون الجيش
الاسلاميه على راسهم
رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان رد
ايضا عبر العربيه مشيرا الى ان الجيش
السوداني وكاي جيش في العالم هدفه ضمان
وحده الدوله بشكل عام وليس العمل من اجل
شخص او جهه ما
[موسيقى]
جميع يعلم ذلك نحن قوات مسلحه نعمل بمثليه
احترافيه وواجبنا حمايه السودان حتى
معظم هذه الاشاعه يعلم المصداقيه ويعلم
انه انها كلمه باطل اريد فيها
الاتهامات ايضا صدرت من بعض القوى
السياسيه لاتباع النظام السابق بالوقوف
وراء نشوب الحرب واستمرارها ومحاوله
تصعيدها خاصه وان العمليه السياسيه
الحاليه هي التي اقصت حزب المؤتمر
وعلى وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يتداول
سودانيون ما يفيد بان انصار البشير يرفضون
صراحه قوات الدعم السريع لكنهم في ذات
الوقت يهددون بالوقوف بوجه الجيش حاله
توقف الحرب والهدف واحد مصلحه فلول البشير
حسن جوليد العربيه
قالت الخارجيه السعوديه ان المملكه اجلت
اليوم 198 شخصا من السودان من جنسيه
مختلفه عبر ميناء جده اضافه الى خمسه
سعوديين واوضحت الخارجيه السعوديه ان
اجمالي عدد من تم اجلائهم من السودان وصل
الى
351 شخصا من سبع وستين دوله
جاؤوها بحثا عن فرص جديده وهاهم يغادرونها
للنجاه بحياتهم نحو عشره الاف شخص من 50
دوله حول العالم تم اجلائهم حتى الان منهم
2250 من جنسيات مختلفه نقل بحرا من ميناء
بورتسودان الى بناء جده في السعوديه
اكثر من 1500 مواطن مصري والمئات من
المواطنين العرب عاشوا السفر الجلاء
الاصعب اكثر من الف كيلو متر بحافلات
نقلتهم الى الحدود المصريه
وال
خشم الباب
ونهب مسلح بصوره عشوائيه احنا دلوقتي جينا
وبيوتنا مش معروف هنلقاه ولا مش مع
حنلقاها الطريقه البري لحد
عشان دي عطبره لحد السنكاتها اخذنا يومين
وسجلنا هنا والله البحريه السعوديه بارك
الله فيهم
400 فرنسي ومئه الماني وغيرهم من الدول
الاجنبيه نقل جوا من مطار عسكري قرب
الخرطوم الى مطار جيبوتي بعثه دبلوماسيه
امريكيه وروسيه واسيويه وجدت هي الاخرى
السبيلا للنجاه من حرب السودان معظم هؤلاء
النازحين كانوا محركا نهضه ماموله في
السودان اطباء ومهندسون ومعلمون قادوا
عجله تنبيه تعثرت
فقهيدوا خارج الحدود لكن ماذا عن
السودانيين الراغبين في النجاه بحياتهم
لقد وقعوا فريسه تجار
الحربات في التاسعه عشان نفصل زمان لما
تصل مصر
يقول هؤلاء الشبان ان تذكره الحافله وصلت
الى 350 دولار سوق حرب سوداء بدات تلوح في
الافق نشاهد لعائلات نزحت الى تشاد بحثا
عن امن وغذاء تذكر بالسنوات مجاعه وجفاف
ولكن هذه المره السبب البشر وليس قله
المطر
تعبنا نحن ما حنطلع من بيوتنا ما حنطلع
احنا هنموت في بيوتنا الموت واحد احنا
اولادنا يقوموا من الصباح عشان يجيبوا لنا
مويه لغايه بالليل مويه عشان نشرب نحن وين
حد وين يا حد وين يا حماتي يا اخي خافوا
الله فينا خافوا الله فينا لا حول ولا قوه
الا بالله
[موسيقى]
ومعنا الان من الخرطومه المحلل العسكريه
الفريق فتح الرحمن المحي الدين سيد فريق
اهلا بك معنا في العربيه بدايه هل تعتقد
ان مبادره الايجاد وحوار ممثلين عن الجيش
والدعم السريع في جوبا يمكن ان تكون له
فرصه
لانهاء هذه الازمه
تعريف الازمه تعريفا صحيحا نتحدث عن ان
طرفين نزاع فهذا تعريف خاطئ للازمه
وبالتالي الممثل
اذا عرفوا الازمه بان هنالك قوات مسلحه
شرعيه في الدوله وهنالك الجسم كان يتبع
لها تمرد عليها هذا التوصيف الصحيح اذا
وصفوا الازمه هكذا انا اعتقد اننا يمكن ان
نصل الى حل الحل يكون الجسم الذي تمرد
يلتقي السلاح ونذهب الى ان نتفاوض بعد ذلك
لا لا ضيق لكن لا يمكن ان نتحدث عن اننا
طرفين نزاع هذا الكلام لا يحل الازمه
لو لو ذهب الطرفان للتفاوض الان
يعني يعد هذا اعترافا ضمنيا بالدعم السريع
كطرف في مقابله في مقابل الجيش
انا كنت اقول لك الدعم السريع هو جسم مقرر
به والزجه في في هذه الحرب يعني دون ان
يدري لماذا زج به فيها الدعم السريع هو
جزء من القوات المسلحه وافرادهم افراد
الشعب السوداني ومرحبا بهم المسلحه ولقد
صدرت عده بيانات تؤكد على ذلك
ونقول الان كل الذين سلموا انفسهم ذرات
المسلحه يعني لا احد ينكر الدعم لكن ننكر
تورط قياده الدعم السريع على الدوله هذا
هو الذي يمكنه الجميع اذا اذا ارادوا ان
يحلوا هذه الازمه اولا يلقوا السلاح ثم
يذهبوا الى التفاوض في كيف يمكن معالجه
هذا الجسم ودمجه في القوات المسلحه
بالطريقه التي تراها المسلحه
لكن ان نتحدث عن طرفين نزاع يعني لكي نجلس
وكاننا
لجسمين متوازيين
عسكريا هل تعتقد ان هذا وارد وارد ان يلقي
الدعم السريع اسلحتهم
هم الان يعني لكي يحقنوا دماءهم ويحقنوا
ما تبقى من من قوتهم من الافضل لهم ان
يمشوا في هذا الطريق ان يقولوا نعم نحن
سنلقي باسلحتنا سنذهب الى التفاوض لا في
ذلك لكن ان نتحدث عن ان هنالك جسمين
متوازيين
جيش للدعم السريع وجيش قوات المسلحه ونسب
للتفاوض هذا يعني اننا سنوجه هذه المعرفه
بعد كل هذه الخسائر الماديه
يعني ما تقوله يعني
يتعارض مع ما يعلنه الدعم السريع على
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي من انه يحقق
انتصارات وبانه ياسر عناصر من الجيش وبان
هناك عناصر من الجيش استسلمت للدعم السريع
هذا كله يقوله في منصاتي هنالك ضباط يعني
خدعوا في اليوم الاول وهم ذاهبون الى
مقرات عملهم فصادم تصادفوا مع عناصر الدعم
السريعه اخذوهم هكذا قدرا هنالك من اخذوا
من منازلهم يعني غدرا ايضا قبل بدايه
القتال حتى يعني في ساعات في الساعه
الاولى للتورد هنالك هؤلاء هم الذين
يتخذونهم البشريه الان يحتورونهم واسئله
لديهم لكن ليس هنالك من ينضم اليهم من
القوات المسلحه
وانا الفكره التي قلت ان اكملها لك ان اذا
احترفنا باننا جيشنا سنذهب للتفاوض هذا
يعني اننا بعد كل هذه الخسائر سنجل هذه
المعركه الى عده سنوات اخرى ثم نعود مره
اخرى لكي نتقاتل وندمر الخرطوم مره اخرى
كما دمرناها الان انا اعتقد ان هذا حديث
لا يقبله عاقل ولا يقولهم منطق والمنطق
يقول اننا اذا اردنا ان ننهي هذا التمرد
يجب ان نعالج الازمه من جذورها الازمه من
جذورها تتعالج ان يكون هنالك جيشا وطنيا
واحدا مسلحه السودانيه وعناصر الدعم
السريع تدمج فيه بالسرعه التي تراها
القوات المسلحه قبل اي حديث
هناك مصادر تقول ان البرهان قبل مبدئيا
بمبادره الايجاد يعني قبل مبدئيا بارسال
ممثلين عن الجيش الى جوبا
صحيح
بيفترض انا انا لا اتحدث باسمه ولا ناطقا
باسمهم ولكن انا اقول ان المنطقه يقول ان
كان هو يريد ان يمضي الى جبه لكي يتفاوض
كجيش موازي
للدعم السريع هذا يعني اننا نؤجل هذه
المعركه لعده سنوات اخرى ثم تنطلق مره
اخرى لكن ان كان يذهب للتفاوض
مسلحه شرعيه في الدوله وهنالك الجسم تمرد
عليها هذا هو المنطق وهذا هو الذي يحقن
الدماء الجسم الذي تمرد يبقى سلاحه يذهب
الى التفاوض في كيفيه معالجه هذه العناصر
الموجوده الان يعني لا احد ينكر الوجود
عناصر الدعم السريع في كل الساحات موجودون
واعدادهم ليست بالسهله فهذا يرجع الى
النوم
لو سمحت لي في هذه المقابله اليوم برزه
تطور لافت في غرب دارفور الاشتباكات
القبليه بين القبائل العربيه
قبائل اخرى هناك اندلعت مره اخرى قبل ان
تهدا هل سيتفجر الوضع في دارفور ايضا
والله انت اصلا الوضع الامني في دارف الله
سنوات
ولكن لا اتوقع ان يتفجر اكثر يعني ولايه
غير شهدت حتى قبل هذه الازمه الاخيره شاهد
الصراعات كثيره يعني تابعتهم انتم قبل عده
شهور كان هنالك اختتال وجبليه في العام
الماضي كان هنالك اختتال
والمنطقه يعني اصلا منطقه فيها احترام
شديد وفيها تداخل قبلي وفيها عدم قبول
للاخر وفي افرازات السياسات الخاطئه في
المركز تنعكس ذلك ايضا عدم قبول للاخر
وهذا كله يعني يجي على الوضع
ولكن يعني امرا يعني اعتقد انه طبيعي
ومقدور عليه
بسهوله الازمه الان المعقده هي ازمه
الخرطوم لانه الاحياء السكنيه ينتشر فيها
هؤلاء
يتخذون من المواطنين بالرعبه الشهريه يعقد
التعامل معهم ويجعل عمليه المعالجه بطيئه
تاتي الهدن هذه ايضا لتكبر المسلحه بقيد
اخر يزيد من تعقيد المشهد ويزيد من اود
الازمه هذه التعقيدات التي يجب ان نعمل
على معالجتها لكي نؤمن الخرطوم اولا ثم
بعد ذلك الولايات كلها يعني ليس هنالك
مشكله تذكر يعني شكرا جزيلا لكم الفريق
فتح الرحمن محيدين المحلل العسكري كنت
معنا من الخرطوم
والى مصر يصل الالف من السودانيين كل يوم
عبر الطرق البريه هربا من الاحداث هناك
ملايين السودانيين يعيشون في مصر ومن
النازحين من يستقر في اسوان قربى او اقرب
المدن المصريه للحدود السودانيه
ومنهم من يتوجه لمدن اخرى وخاصه القاهره
في كنف الاقارب او المعارف مراسل العربيه
التقى احدى العائلات الفاره من السودان
ونقل قصتها في سياق التقرير التالي
ان تعود الى منزلك مطمئنا انك ستجد اسرتك
في امان هذا يساوي الكثير عند عبد اللطيف
حامد المقيم في مصر منذ سنوات بعد ان كاد
القلق يفتك به خوفا على اسرته التي كانت
تحاول الهروب من الاشتباكات الدائره في
السودان ووصلت بسلام الى مصر منذ ثلاثه
ايام انا كنت جالي جدا وكنت متابعا
بالتلفون عبر التلفونات وعبر الواتساب
لحظه انه الاتصال اتقطع بيني وبينه بكون
خايف وعايش في رعب شديد انه البلد ما امنه
يعني حتى لحد الحمد لله لحد ما وصلوا
اسطوان وكنت متابعين خطوه بخطوه وكلمه
بكلمه قرار الخروج من كسلا ومن السودان
صوب مصر اتخذته السيده سوسن وابنتها ريما
خوفا على اولادهما قبل الحرب كانت صعبه
وهسه زاد الوضع سوق عندنا العيش في
المخابز ما في الغاز ما في كهرباء ما في
مويه ما في يعني تضرريات الحياه انعدمت
تماما يعني في اي لحظه نحن ممكن نضيع
اولاديه يضعوا مني اما الرحله الطويله
التي استغرقت ثلاثه ايام فكانت خليطا من
المشقه والخوف في الطريق ماذا
ياكلوا عايزين يشربوا عايزين يناموا
مرتاحين فهمته بعدين صوت النار بيخافوا في
الايام العاديه غير الحرب كان في نهر
يعني انت بتجي ماشي بالعربيه فينا في ناس
بيموت وكده في الطريق يعني هسه احنا لما
جاي قلبنا في يدنا في المرعب
يعني
في الشوارع ويجر رصاص المباني بتوعه
والحريق لا نحن محتاجين دكتور نفساني
والله العظيم يعني يعني انا ما اعرف انا
ما ما قريت المنفصل لكن الوضع من جوه
خربان يعني مستحيل انك تشوف يعني انت في
لحظه كنت قاعد في بيتك مطمئن فجاه تلقى
نفسك
اخيرا تم لم شمل الاسره بعد عناء تركوه
وراء ظهورهم مع ما تركوه من امتعه في
بيتهم المغلق في كسلا فهم جاءوا باقل
القليل من الملابس ويشعرون بعدم الثقه في
ان محنتهم ستنتهي قريبا تامر نصرت العربيه
القاهره
الدكتور محمد ابراهيم المتحدث باسم وزاره
الصحه السودانيه للعربيه قال ان مئه
مستشفى فقط هو عدد المستشفيات العامله
بالخرطوم فيما خرجت اربعه وثلاثون مستشفى
عن الخدمه عدد المسلسلات العامله الان
بالحد الادنى من القوى العامله هي مئه
مستشفى تقدم الخدمات على مستوى الطاري
من مجمل 134 مستشفى في ولايه الخرطوم على
القطاعين الغطاء الحكومي والقطاع الخاصي
34 مستشفى هي خارج الخدمه نسبه لوجود هذه
المستشفيات في الاماكن التي مازال
الاشتباك حولها
مجمل عدد الاصابات
من تاريخ
15/4 وحتى اليوم
2,159 حاله اصابه منها 1108 حاله في
مستشفيات الحكوميه
والف41 قطاع الخاص مجمل عدد الوفيات
الموثقه عندنا
بشهادات وفاء او تحويل الى المسارح 155
حاله 51 حاله وفاه في مسيفرات القطاع
العام و14 حاله القطاع الخاص
تحذير اممي من كارثه صحيه في السودان 24
الف امراه سيلدن دون رعايه صحيه 50 الف
طفل يواجهون مخاطر حقيقيه
احدى وستون في المئه من المنشات الصحيه
مغلقه
16% من المرافق الصحيه تمارس عملها
المراكز المخصصه لمنع تفشي الاوبئه توقفت
عن العمل مع امكانيه وقوع اصابات بسبب شرب
مياه غير صالحه تسجيل 16 هجمه على مراكز
المنظمه الطبيه ومقتل ثمانيه اشخاص
الاستيلاء على مختبر طبي يثير مخاوف من
مخاطر بيولوجيه والتلاعب بالعينات
المخزونه
حذر نائب الامين العام للامن الغذائي في
السودان حمزه سرور من ازمه غذائيه محققه
في البلاد سرور قال ان الوضع ما زال مخيفا
مما اثر على استيراد الاحتياجات الغذائيه
اللازمه للمواطنين وارتفاع الاسعار ودعا
سرور المؤسسات الدوليه الى انقاذ السودان
من الازمه مشيرا الى ان المخزون الحكومي
في وضع سيء في حال تناقصه مرجعا تضاعف
اسعار
الاسعار الى اغلاق اكثر من 90% من الاسواق
نتيجه الاوضاع الامنيه
وبالحديث عن اسعار السلع الاساسيه فهي
تؤرق السودانيه حيث ازدادت الى اضعاف مما
كانت عليه قبل الحرب في ولايات عده في
السودان نتابع
فوضى الاسعار
صدمه جديده على السودانيين تزيد الطين بله
نازحون هربوا الى مدن بعيده عن الخرطوم
الالاف هرب من المعارك الى شبح ارتفاع
الاسعار
ولايه الجزيره على بعد 160 كيلومترا من
العاصمه ارتفعت فيها الاسعار بنسبه اربعين
الى مئه في المئه
المواد التموينيه ان توفرت وصلت اضعاف
السعر رغيف الخبز زاد عشره اضعاف مع موجات
النزوح غرف للايجار قدرت بمئه دولار
وقود على جنبات الطريق ب 80 دولارا
ارتفاع مرعب في الاسعار طال جميع ولايات
السودان
اما الان فالى موجز لابرز الاخبار الدوليه
[موسيقى]
بعد اول محادثه هاتفيه بين الرئيس الصيني
شي مع نظيره الاوكراني منذ بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا اعلنت الحكومه الصينيه انها
سترسل ممثلا خاصا عن بكين الى اوكرانيا
ودول اخرى لاجراء محادثات معمقه مع جميع
الاطراف من اجل التواصل الى تسويه سياسيه
وقال مسؤول صينيين محادثات تشيجنبينج مع
موقف الصين
واحساسها بالمسؤوليه
من جانبه قال رئيس
الاوكرانيشي قال انه لا سلام مع روسيا على
حساب التنازلات الاقليميه من جانبه قال
الرئيس الصيني ان بلاده ستقوم بارسال ممثل
خاص عن الحكومه الصينيه الى اوكرانيا
لاجراء اتصال مع جميع اطراف النزاع للتوصل
الى حل بشان تسويه الازمه السياسيه
الاوكرانيه مؤكدا بان بلاده لن تختار ان
تكون متفرجا على الازمه الاوكرانيه
اوضح مندوب روسيا لدى الامم المتحده انه
لم يتم احراز تقدم حقيقي لحل القضايا التي
اثرتها موسكو بشان اتفاق تصدير الحبوب عبر
البحر الاسود والذي من المقرر ان ينتهي
العمل به الشهره المقبل مشيرا الى ان
روسيا لن توافق على التمديد ما لم يقم
الغرب بازاله العراقيل التي تعيق الصادرات
الروسيه من الحبوب والاسمده
افادت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بان القوات
البيلاروسيه يتم تدريبها في روسيا لتشغيل
انظمه صواريخ اسكندر بحسب الوزاره فان
الاطقمات تتدرب في مكان غير محدد جنوبي
روسيا منذ الثالث من الشهر الجاري
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره العدل الامريكيه ان السلطات
الرومانيه اعتقلت اللبنانيه محمد ابراهيم
بزي احد ابرز ممولي حزب الله والمدرج على
لائحه الارهاب الامريكيه منذ 2018 لدى
وصوله الى مطار بوخارست ويحمل بذي الذي
يبلغ من العمر 58 عاما الجنسيتين
اللبنانيه والبلجيكيه وكانت واشنطن رصدت
مكافاه بعشره ملايين دولار مقابل معلومات
عن مكان تواجد بذي الذي ساهم بدعم حزب
الله وتمويله على مدى سنوات وفق وزاره
العدل الامريكيه
قال وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه انه ليس من
المرجح التغلب على كل الخلافات مع الصين
الا انه توقع ان تحافظ بكينه على
التزاماتها الدوليه
يجب ان نتعامل مع الصين عند الضروره وان
نكون واقعيين بشان التعامل مع الصين وهذا
يعني عدم التراجع عن مبدا واضح لا نتوقع
ان يتم التغلب على خلافاتنا مع الصين
بسرعه لكننا نتوقع ان تراعي الصين
القوانين والالتزامات التي تعهدت بها
صوت مجلس العموم البريطانيه على قانون
يمنع المهاجرين القادمين بصوره غير شرعيه
من طلب اللجوء والاقامه لاحقا على اراضي
المملكه البريطانيه حيث صوت 230 نائبا مع
القانون المقابل 289 نائبا ضد القانون
اعلنت رئيسه الوزراء الفرنسيه الى بيان
لها ان مشروع قانون الهجره الذي طلب به
الرئيس سيتم تاجيله وذلك لاعداد متوفر
التصويت الكافي على نص القانون مما يؤجل
الطرحه المفترض له واكدت بون ان حكومه
بلادها تنظر الى هذه المساله كاولويه
مشيره الى ان فرنسا اعلنت عن تعبئه 150
شرطيا اضافيا على الحدود الايطاليه
اعتبارا من الاسبوع المقبل لمواجهه ضغوط
الهجره المتزايده
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن خلال مؤتمر
صحفيين جمعه بنظيره الكوريه الجنوبي ان
العلاقات الدفاعيه بين البلدين متينه
للغايه هذه التصريحات تاتي بعدما اعلنت
واشنطن انها سترسل غواصه نوويه لتتوقف في
كوريا الجنوبيه في خطوه لتعزيز قدرات
الردع في مواجهه كوريا الشماليه
ان معاهده الدفاع المتبادل التي تجمعنا
متينه وهذا يشمل التزامنا بالردع الموسع
وذلك يشمل التهديد النووي والرابع النووي
انها مهمه بشكل خاص في مواجهه التهديدات
المتزايده لكوريا الشماليه والانتهاك
الصارخ للعقوبات الامريكيه نواصل السعي
لتحقيق انجازات دبلوماسيه جاده لتعزيز
الاستقرار في شبه الجزيره والحد من خطر
انتشار اسلحه الدمار الشامل ومعالجه
الاوضاع الانسانيه
والمتعلقه بحقوق الانسان لشعب كوريا
الشماليه
وفي سياق اخر قال الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن انه قد لا يكون الشخص الوحيد الذي
يمكنه هزيمه الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
في انتخابات 2024 لكنه يعرف ترامب بشكل
جيد والخطر الذي يمثله على الديمقراطيه في
الولايات المتحده بايدن اكده سعيه لطمانه
الامريكيين بانه يتمتع بصحه جيده لفتره
ولايه ثانيه على الرغم من تقدمه في السن
انه مستعد لمواجهه المحتمل ضد دونالد
ترامب في خوض الانتخابات
كانت هذه ابرز اخبار العالم الان نعود
لاستكمال تغطيه احداث السودان ساعه جديده
الان مع الزميل طاهر بركه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات